hello welcome to the debate on Sky News
I'm Martin Stanford here's our take on
developments brought together from
America the UK and around the world
cranking up the rhetoric against Islamic
state but will the words be matched by
actions but we are making a difference
on the ground when I see the dash beam
hit in its own huntland plus China slow
down as the Chinese economy catches a
cold does the rest of the world get the
financial flu
it looks like a new chapter in the fight
against daesh or so-called Islamic state
is going to be opened the British and
American defense secretaries are meeting
as we record this show with some of
their European counterparts to work out
how they can ramp up action against is
where are we in this fight here's the
assessment of the british defence
secretary well we are making a
difference on the ground we're now
seeing that the dash beam hit in its own
heartland we're seeing a tax on its oil
wells and we're beginning to see a tax
on its command and control buildings in
mosul for example so the dash is now
under pressure the the task now is to
you know is to capitalize on that and
some of the setbacks they've had and for
the coalition now to really push forward
and so identify how we can tighten the
noose around the the head of the snake
as I comment well as usual the Democrat
commentator Geoffrey Robinson is
standing by in New York conservative
commentator Armstrong Williams is in
Washington DC Jeffrey do you think these
airstrikes are having any effect they
clearly are I don't think it's a matter
if we do fight defeat ISIL I think it's
a question of when and sooner rather
than later would be good but it has to
do with the stomach we have for the
fight I worry about something and it's
this idea of the coalition it is
obviously good for all of Western Europe
especially Britain to join the United
States in this coalition to bring in the
Arab nations and to defeat ISIL as soon
as possible but there is a geopolitical
side to this and I think that there are
senior voices in the British military
who were saying that bombing an
increased bombing will make Britain
popular with the United States but it
may not make Britain's safer and there
is this balance that has to be has to be
made between the countries uh I mean I
go back to the Gulf War one when France
wanted to be seen helping the coalition
to defeat Saddam Hussein so the French
sent an aircraft carrier into the Gulf
but France being French they took the
planes off first because it would be
politically unwise to upset their big
markets in the in the Middle East so
there are these geopolitical
considerations and I just wonder at what
point does Britain say yeah sure we'll
continue the bombing and we'll we'll add
maybe some elite ground forces but not a
lot and we're going to do whatever we
have to do to be seen to be helpful but
we really don't want to go overboard and
endanger our own territory by being too
helpful and Armstrong you don't think we
should either as UK all the USA be doing
much more than this bombing campaign no
troops for instance well certainly not
in the definition of having ground
troops I think that is a universal
understanding that you don't want to see
Western troops on the ground fighting
Muslims you want to be able to arm
people who have proven to be allies in
that region like the curs and and those
that we've built relationships and Trust
with in that region I also think that it
would be wise so not always discuss our
strategy and how we move forward to
fight ISIL I do think it's important
that we in our own way find a way to off
the record talk to the Russians and talk
to the Israelis about particularly
tactics for the Israelis have used that
have been rather work proven to be very
beneficial and very devastating and
fighting our enemy and fighting this
growing demon that continues just to
show itself with little resource since
in that region III think airstrikes are
fine as long as those airstrikes are
targeted in a way where innocent
civilians the very people that we're
trying to defend and trying to help them
reclaim so much of the life that they've
lost and they've suffered the most from
this devastating devastation as long as
these strikes are not killing innocent
civilians and then also what you have to
understand when you have these
airstrikes you just destroyed
infrastructure that's going to require
great resources to rebuild these
countries and these and these nations
and so I think it's important that
United States and our allies in that
region work together and we also build
relationships that people that we
sometimes may be at odds with but also
find that Isis that ISIL is a just as a
greater threat to them I think we have
to change our tactics i think special
ops is is something that should not be
off the table you may have ground groups
but not in a sense and the understanding
of the definition that we would think of
the man sometimes we gotta fight the
devil with sometimes with the devilish
tactics well here's a guy who may be
able to help us with the idea of special
ops let's speak to major general chip
Chapman former head of British
counterterrorism he was a senior
military advisor to US Central Command
and Major General thank you for being
with us today do you think the airstrike
campaign is working as its designers
hoped it would well you've got to
understand what the air strikes are
about and the air strikes really are
about containment and that is stopping
ISIL expanding their territory so in
that sense they're correct the British
contribution to that can only be more
than a minor thickening because there is
only one superpower and ninety to
ninety-five percent of the strikes are
from the US but of course a coalition is
something you want and UNSCR 2249 in
November said that ISIL was an
unprecedented threat to international
peace and security and wanted every
nation to join in in taking them on when
the British and American politicians are
saying it's time to up the ante and to
really push home their advantage what do
you think they've got in mind well I'm
not too sure what that means to be
honest I don't think there's anything
wrong with the strategy and although we
heard about geopolitics of course the
politics in each country still intrude
so for example I don't think whilst you
have one year left of an Obama
administration that you're going to
going to have much more than is going on
the moment we've already had an
announcement in the last month of
another 250 special operations forces
will be going to the sort of
turkish-syrian border to try and thicken
up the training there so in terms of the
politics of both the UK and the US what
we're doing at the moment is probably
appropriate it's worth saying that I
think I still have reached its zenith
CENTCOM have said that ISIL is in a
defensive crouch they've lost 30
forty percent of territory in Iraq
they've lost seventeen thousand square
kilometers in Syria they are certainly
on the back foot and you could see that
from the pronouncements of Baghdadi in
his sort of audio message of the 26 of
December 2015 I'll bring the others in a
minute but one more thought here which I
think everybody regards as the Americans
didn't quite get right during Iraq was
what's next what's the post-conflict
plan do you think America the UK anyone
else has got a post-conflict plan here
well I think again if you look back to
something that Bob nella who's the
Commandant of the US Marine Corps said
in December he sort of said could we go
to rekar and pound these guys into the
ground absolutely but then what there's
nothing there that I want Who am I
supposed to hand it over to and this is
a problem of governance and it's a
problem of legitimacy we could do go
with a strong military force on the
ground and take things out but we'd be
in the same dilemma as we had after the
Iraqi invasion it was the war which came
off to the war that we did not get right
and we cannot get that right without
proxies and partners in the Middle East
it is partly their problem we can help
them with that problem we cannot win it
for them let's bring in Jeffrey and
Armstrong Jeffrey it's going to be about
partnerships in the end it's going to be
about two things it's certainly going to
be about partnerships in the region but
it's also about Syria and getting rid of
Assad I don't think you can possibly
have a solution to the ISIL problem as
long as Assad still around I don't think
you can have a suitable partnership with
any of the people who might join us from
Syria until you get rid of Assad so it's
a it's an enormously complex situation
but it's not going to get solved by just
bombing I like the idea of drones by the
way the Republicans are running around
in there maniacal style saying carpet
bomb them and and we'll end it that way
we can't you can be stupid you can't
carpet bomb them that doesn't play with
the American timetable political
timetable does it because everyone's
doing battle on the campaign trail
they're not really focused on what's
next for northern Syria
but you got to separate the campaign
rhetoric that's being ratchet up to
reality of the consequences of how we go
for in the decision making you know I
would just be interested in from the
general I'm just curious and it's a take
on what Jeffrey was just talking about
and get rid of Assad we always seem to
think that getting rid of some bloody
dictator is going to always pave the way
for the successes that we're looking for
as the general looks back over the
campaign by President Bush to go in Iraq
where we eliminated Sodom who's saying
and the way he was sort of like an
effigy in his death and how he's dragged
down the streets I had a state and those
images that were left even the loyalists
to him and then under Obama we moved on
to Libya and we took out Muammar Qaddafi
and we saw what happened in an era of
change and if we still had those despots
in place today with it wouldn't we be
talking about something else instead of
Isis in the threat of Isis well let's go
to the Assad question first the Assad
question really does show the complexity
of the geopolitics of the region
certainly from the sunny states from the
GCC states the Gulf Cooperation Council
they obviously want to see a sad go
turkey wants to see a sad go Iran wants
to see a sad stay Hezbollah want to see
us Assad stay and the Russians want to
see SAT Mossad stay so you've got the
complexity there of a lot of groups
wanting different things from the Saudi
perspective of course this is partly a
Saudi Iranian sunni-shia split and the
complexity of that which came out of
both the nuclear deal with Iran and the
fact that Iraq sorry Saudi Arabia had a
34 nation alliance but excluded Syria
excluded Iraq and excluded Iran shows
the complexity of Syria I'm slightly
optimistic about the future of Iraq in
the next year I'm absolutely pessimistic
about the future of Syria and any hope
of a settlement there in the next year
can I just ask you about the borders
when you say you're optimistic about
Iraq under its present borders or do you
a bit of redrawing of borders is
inevitable perhaps with both Iraq and
Syria well certainly the pronouncements
from the united states and international
community are that you should maintain
the borders as they exist that doesn't
mean you'll have the same political
settlement as currently exists whether
you have confederation in iraq is up for
debate about how the Turkmen how the
Kurds have the shear how the sunnies
actually govern themselves Syria is just
such a complex kaleidoscope of
challenges at the moment that it's just
difficult to see a way ahead there the
Israelis for example say that it will
take 50 years to sort Syria add 50 but
that's present mystic bunny ones yet
yeah stick Geoffrey let's pivot to the
campaign shall we why how would Hillary
Clinton I know your favored candidate
sort this out well she's been very very
explicit on what she wants to do and and
that's continued the bombing maybe up
the bombing and use special forces but
form this coalition I think she also
understands that Syria is a real part of
the problem this is this is not the same
thing as Armstrong has alluded to
qaddafi Mubarak and Saddam Hussein now
the Syrian situation because they're in
the midst of a civil war some of the
people who are fighting against Assad
would probably join the coalition
against ISIL but they're already tied up
it's a it's an enormously complicated
and I I kind of wondered because the
general talk said 50 years I wonder just
from a military standpoint if what we're
seeing now is not a precursor to what
militaries will be in 50 years I mean is
it general is the future of the of the
American and British military an elite
strike force pilotless Air Force's
drones mach3 cruise missiles on on
surface seabourn platforms or are we
still going to have a big cavalry and
tanks just in case the Russians decide
to come across the German border we
can't afford both and it looks to me
like we have to make a choice eventually
what do you think it'll be well actually
the the global risks 2016 paper has come
out in the last week and it sort of said
in the secure
fear that you've actually got both of
those problems you have the problem of
fragile states and the military which
might deal with that and I'll come on to
that in a minute and secondly you have
the interest on the developed state
still which would need need a
maintenance of aircraft carriers tanks
and things like that you could see a
strategy of how you might take places
like wrecker and it isn't as people
perceive like a kind of Stalingrad and
it would need an investment force which
needs to be both coalition and from the
Gulf states it would use persistent
surveillance from drones to identify the
targets and to stop ISIL Manning
bulldozer blitzkrieg and all the
artillery systems and things like that
it would lead to cyber warfare where we
not knock out all their means of
communication and go go dark and then it
would need a listening campaign so that
when they when we see them from the
persistent drone strikes we would take
them out with aircraft and that would be
with very few casualties as we sort of
saw in the retaking of Ramadi recently
so you have a force for that and you
still need a force while the Russian
bear seems to be at least unleashing its
claws slightly major-general chip
Chapman thank you for being with us
today reminder you can catch up with the
Sky News debate on Apple TV Roku and
catch up and of course at Sky News com /
us next is the tiger losing its raw
China has reported a slowing of its rate
of growth its lowest rate for a quarter
of a century if the workshop of the
world is being hard hit should we be
worried well Gabriel will Dow is the
Financial Times correspondent in
Shanghai has this taken even the Chinese
by surprise I don't think it's taken the
Chinese by surprise China's economy has
actually been slowing for the last five
years so what we saw was another notch
in down of growth last year and Chinese
leaders are facing some serious
difficulties in their own economy where
we see that the engines of the economy
that have really driven China's
economic miracle over the last three
decades those traditional growth engines
are now in pretty deep trouble so we're
talking about heavy industry we're
talking about coal mining we're talking
about real estate and infrastructure
construction so China's leadership has a
big challenge when it comes to
maintaining employment maintaining
social stability for a whole generation
of young Chinese that have really known
nothing but prosperity I think though
when we're looking at the impact for the
global economy and for the u.s. in
particular the picture is is less bleak
the US economy isn't that exposed to
China at least not directly uh and what
about Europe proposed if we're if we're
concerned about our own backyard various
European nations have got quite used to
exploiting this growth of China have now
they have so smaller economies like
Germany which is certainly a large
economy compared to its European
neighbors but is small compared to the
u.s. a country like Germany really
generates a lot of its growth by
exporting to China and and they and many
German companies have been quite
successful in selling heavy machinery
and engineering services to China so
they have very bad reason to be
concerned and and and especially those
who've been feeding those traditional
growth engines on the other hand if you
look at economies like the UK for
example they're actually well poised to
benefit from a transition underway in
the economy where these traditional
growth drivers the heavy industry is
declining but we're seeing a growth in
an in the new economy in China that
notably the services sector so for a
country like the UK they're very well
suited to be exporting services like
education entertainment and culture
health care and not only to be exporting
them budget for British companies to be
investing in China and providing those
services directly so the impact on other
countries really depends on what kind of
where you stand and what and what kind
of goods and services you specialize in
up for the American big tech giant
something they've got something of a
schizophrenic relationship with China
haven't though because much of the
manufacturing for their profit comes
from Chinese factories but
they also have the downside of a lot of
their goods and services being copied
and cloned in China that's right of
course some of the most familiar tech
names like Twitter and Facebook are
banned in China the internet sensors
don't allow amean and Chinese citizens
living in China to access those websites
other tech companies like uber for
example is actually growing quite
swiftly here they are invested directly
on the ground providing local services
the companies that rely on tech
components on purchasing tech components
to from China are are also in a pretty
good position because what we're seeing
in China is actually deflation which is
which is very bad for China's economy
but is probably good for companies like
Apple that source tech components from
from China the prices for the components
they source are going down let's bring
in Jeffrey in New York and Armstrong
standing by in Washington Armstrong
you're a businessman what do you think
you or your business sector will be
affected by a China slow down you know
his interested in listening to this
conversation because this slowdown has
been gone for a little over a decade and
the slow down on this economy and China
will have negative impacts on the
markets that are close to related to the
economy one of them being the USA is in
the in our country a decrease in their
level of consuming spending will affect
the US exports negatively and if the
u.s. is not successful Martin and sort
of shifting to other markets then based
on the gpd be formula a decrease in our
US gdp at least in the short run can be
expected and i also think in terms of
the exports decreasing and imports being
less affected from those negative
developments and and it will have a pack
on the deficit in the u.s. balance of
trade with China I think well why and go
further and the long run and i also
think um and your guests can come in on
this if China continues to evolve
unfavorably in the
United States's economy is going to be
through the selling of these Treasury
securities the Chinese government may
want to sell off part of these
securities to use the proceeds for
economic stimulus all these things
should be of great concern because
especially with the setting off for this
economic stimulus it could be a
potential massive selling of the US
Treasury securities which creates a real
threat to US economy Gabriel you want to
pick that up yeah I mean people have
talked a lot about the impact and the
potential risks from China's role in the
US Treasury market I think those
concerns are probably overblown the US
Treasury market is very liquid yes
China's purchase of us treasuries is
falling in fact they're selling us
treasuries on a net basis as they try to
combat some of the very severe capital
outflow that their economies
experiencing but there are plenty of
buyers for us treasuries and in fact we
see that the Treasury yields are still
very low in fact their indications that
that because investors are worries about
a us recession are starting to to pick
up we're seeing the Treasury yields
actually come down despite the raising
of interest rates by the Federal Reserve
Jeffrey it's interesting that Gabriel
talks about a recession of the American
economy those on a little uptick here
isn't it I mean you brought interest
rates back from there almost zero or
negative is it going to be adversely
affected by this problem the other side
of the world well we live in a global
village to use the very beds for term
and yes what happens if China sneezes
other people can catch a cold Japan
certainly is very vulnerable what
worries me about China several things
and it has all has to do with the
balance of trade between the u.s. and
china we need a two-way trade but it has
to be a level playing field and I don't
think a lot of companies trust China I
don't know that we can trust their
figures I think they're their level of
corporate espionage and stealing of
intellectual property is way out of
control and I don't know what's being
done
on a serious basis except shallow
promises from the Chinese government
that no we're not doing it when in fact
there's an entire military brigade sighs
operation in in Beijing that is aimed at
doing nothing but stealing intellectual
property from the West I worry about
Hong Kong and the promises that were
made about keeping Hong Kong free and
those of the Chinese government is now
reneging on some of them and I worry
mostly about the manipulation of the UN
for them to fool around with their
currency has serious trade effects on us
and until they start playing as mature
honest brokers in this world trade
market we have a lot to worry about and
they're not doing that now a Gabriel
what about India what about Japan other
repercussions closer to China that may
well be felt in their economies too I
think so certainly Japan is more exposed
to China as a share of their economy
than the u.s. I think though the
countries where we're going to see the
biggest impact from the Chinese slow
down are the commodity producing
countries in fact we're already seeing
that over the last year with the
collapse and commodity prices we're
talking about about crude oil we're
talking about iron ore we're talking
about copper these countries that again
have grown very rich over the last 10-15
years selling these products Australia
Brazil Russia much of Africa Latin
America these countries which are not
really selling value-added product and
services but just pulling stuff out of
the ground and selling to China with the
transition underway in China's economy
towards services and away from heavy
industry the demand for these economy
these commodities is no longer what it
was and countries that have based their
economies around selling these products
to China are really feeling the pain but
countries like Japan are still i mean
the the high-tech products that japan
cells I mean China's consumers are going
to continue to demand those things even
if they demand you know less steel and
and and copper wire so so um you know
again it depends on where you stand
Gabriel will doubt thank you very much
indeed for joining us from Shanghai now
let me check a thing or two with our
state-of-the-art modern media men I'm
going to ask you about passwords because
a survey just out found that in 2015
guess what the most popular passwords
were they are and here they come 123456
and password how about that things
haven't really changed Geoffrey
Armstrong tell me you do better than
that Geoffrey what's your password well
don't tell me what it is but have you
changed it and is it something more
complicated than that yes because when
you reach Armstrong's age you can't
remember anything except password 123456
so what I do and I worry seriously about
so many people banks and companies i
deal with online who asked for mother's
maiden name what i do to protect myself
is I change my mother every six months
I'm strong what do you do for those
multiple passwords you have to try and
remember you know Geoffrey I really
appreciate all your flattery oh but I
must tell you our passwords and
usernames are so complicated you will
have a very hard time cracking our
systems that's why they've never been
cracked you know Martin we change our
passwords and usernames every three
months without delay every three months
and sometimes it comes from some that
may not want to err apply something that
they funny may happen is the craziest
things that we come up with it will be
very difficult for someone cracking our
passwords well he hasn't happened yet
well fingers crossed thank you very very
much indeed and we wish you well and
that's it for this edition of the debate
you can continue watching sky news on
Apple TV Roku and catch up and of course
on Sky News calm until next time goodbye